哈喽，哈喽，各位听友大家好，我是老潘。
哈喽，大家好，我是Robin。
欢迎来到PhotoRyzen播客视频画子栏目《马格南小方片》改变摄影师一生的照片系列。
我们将用57的内容和大家一起探索《马格南摄影师》的职业生涯和创作历程。
本栏目由知名相机租领品牌《蓝拓相机租领》冠名播出。
作为摄影师，我们每个人都用过蓝拓。
只做摄影相关器材与服务的蓝拓，希望用摄影点亮十亿人的生活，感谢赞助商。
我们回到小方片，今天的话是我们的第29期节目进程过半，然后我们也聊了非常多的摄影师。
今天我们会来到一位其实我们之前不是特别熟悉，
但是做准备然后看他的一些材料的时候，
我们觉得好有意思的一位摄影师，就是Peter Marlow，彼得马洛。
先请Robin来分享一下Peter的背景。
就像老潘刚刚所说的，就看到他作品的时候，
我发现从早期到后期变化却挺大，而且非常多元。
无论是早期那种视觉敏感度跟后期严谨的秩序感，
其实很大程度上就是源于他独特的一个家庭背景跟成长环境。
他是1952年出生于英国沃里克郡。
他的爸爸叫约翰·马洛是英国的阿姆斯特朗西德利以及老斯莱斯公司的机械工程师。
他曾经深度参与了协和式超音速飞机发动机的研发。
所以他后来拍那个协和的项目，对吧？
对，所以协和并不是商业伪拍项目，而是他觉得跟他父亲相关，
然后后来不是要停产那个阶段吗？他去拍摄了那个。
但是还是获得了很多的拍摄许可的，我看他拍到了驾驶舱这些东西。
对，他的母亲是一名精密的工程制图员，
所以他出生于一个很德系的家庭，
对，很功科中产家庭。
所以吴行忠也塑造了他日后创作中对透视也好，对几何线条的这种控制。
就非常严谨的一个创作方式到晚期的时候。
对，他的摄影生涯启谋非常早，他五岁就有了自己的第一台相机，
是一台塑料的柯达相机，跟敦的差不多。
然后八岁的时候他已经在自己的在自己家地下室搭建了暗房，
并且逐渐拍摄关于家人、朋友，还有当时那种小朋友感兴趣的各种活动的摄影项目，
就非常小的项目。
就非常小的时候就已经找到了自己的这种拍摄的兴趣点。
对,对。
然后在布里斯托文法学院完成中学学业后，
他考上了曼托斯特大学的心理学，在1974年毕业。
然后1974年毕业之后，他并没有继续生造，
他去了一艘邮轮上拍照，去应聘那种邮轮的摄影师，
而且是通过非常积贼的方式，他并没有拿自己早年的那些作品，
他向一个朋友借了一套作品集去应聘。
为什么？
就因为那种可能偏商业，他的朋友是做那种商业摄影的，
他就用朋友的这种作品集去应聘上了这个岗位，
然后赚了一些钱。
下次我有什么需要去的，我就借你的作品集去。
然后他利用在邮轮上积累的资金去中美洲进行了一个旅行跟拍摄。
他用这些作品去申请了当时在巴黎的Sigma这个图片社，
对，就申请上了，他就为Sigma进行工作。
在Sigma工作期间，他作为占地摄影师，
奔波于北埃尔兰、黎巴嫩、安格拉以及菲律宾等局势非常动荡的冲突一线，
但是在这个期间也是带来了生理上的恐惧，
就可能为日后他转型埋下了一个伏笔，
也引发了他对新闻摄影职业伦理的深刻的质疑。
他逐渐意识到，就看似充满人道主义关怀的新闻摄影行业，
其实充斥着非常多，可能是摄影是为了名利而进行的一种非常惨烈的竞争。
他看到了这些也进行了反思，
所以他在1980年代回到英国本土时候，
他其实创作上就已经发生了转型，
他在立物补拍社的那个项目。
对，你看他现在在马格南的网站上也非常有意思，
就是每个人不是有一个摄影师的主页吗？
主页里面会有一些摄影师的精选照片或者代表作，
他就是所有的代表作都是他中后期的作品，
都是一系列的彩色，然后正方形的构图比非常平和，
他早期的那些作品他一张都没有放上去了，
所以可能确实那个时候的心理上的这种影响还是挺大的。
对，也是在1980年他回来之后，
开始与马格南图片社建立联系，
并且在1986年正式成为马格南的会员，
1987年他和另一位，我记得也是英国的摄影师，
我们之前介绍过，就是克里斯、斯蒂尔、伯金斯，
他们共同创立了马格南的伦敦办公室，
也是将马格南引入到布列顶群岛，
在此后的职业生涯中，他两度出任马格南图片社的主席，
包括我们非常熟悉也非常尊敬的马丁帕尔，
曾经对马洛做出过非常高的学术评价，
他说我们很难去高估马洛对马格南的发展所作出的历史性贡献，
我们经常会说马丁帕尔对马格南的发展作出了历史性贡献，
对，然后他也将去评价马洛，
对马丁帕尔是一个很擅长鼓励别人的人，
我觉得他经常会对于同事然后或者是一些晚辈都会给很好的评价，
对，包括他的基金会其实也一直在自助年轻的摄影师，
年轻的这些创作者，就真的是一个很了不起的人，
对，他一年会做四场展览，我记得，
就是一个是专门给一些受忽视的摄影师，
还有一个就是给年轻的摄影师，
对，所以马丁确实对于整个，不光是马格南对于整个摄影的贡献都是非常大的，
对，他们都是英国摄影师，
都是英国摄影师，对，那么回到这张小方片，
这张小方片的话，其实从画面上说很简单，
在一个温泉的场景下，
你可以看到一双脚从水里伸出来，然后水上有脚的倒影，
背后呢，就是感觉是有山，有树有雾气，
这样的一个画面非常平静，非常简单的照片，
跟刚才Robin所提到， Peter Marlowe在早期的创作是完全不一样的，
在这张小方片的背后呢，他其实也写了相应的文字，
他说，20000年的一个清晨，我被我的日本联络人，就是Fixer，
日本Fixer，叫做门鞋一腾，一头Cadovacchi，
从床上拽了起来，他耐心惊人，带着我穿行在这个机灵人困惑，
又最终令人着迷的国家，
我们走到一条河边脱光了衣服，
走进河流中央喷涌而出的温泉里，
那时我的职业生涯正在走到一个阶段，
我开始明白我的照片并不需要依靠事件本身来推动，
摄影与作者性很大程度上关乎自信，
而我也开始理解，我自己可以不那么具有侵入性，
可以让情境自行发展，
并在那些普通的过渡的瞬间里发现照片，
那一刻尤其奇妙，物气热度与含义，
同时存在于一个地方，拍下自己双脚的那张照片，
正是我从那次经历中真正保留下来的东西，
在那样的情境里，以新闻式的方式去拍摄似乎是错误的，
所以我只是试着通过让自己成为照片的一部分，
来表达有关于我的体验，
我尽量不让我的庞轴相机粘到水，
可能是一台莱卡，只是平静地躺下靠着，放松下来，
并且拍下自己的双脚，
归根结底我努力让照片自然发生，
因为现在的我足够有信心，
相信他们总会发生，
怎么能比这更简单的呢？
Peter Marlowe，这是他在这个小方面背后写下的文字，
是一个很思考性的文字，
是，这已经到中后期了我觉得，
2000年左右了嘛，
他是16年去世的，
所以在他职业生涯应该处于一个比较晚期的阶段了，
那我在看完Peter Marlowe的这些作品之后，
我的第一个感受就是，
他是一个一直在质疑自己，
然后也在质疑摄影的摄影室，
对吧?
从早期的拍占地，拍计时，
包括刚才Robin其实，
我忘记有没有提到，
他回到丽舞浦之后，
拍摄的那个有关于80年代丽舞浦困境的项目，
丽舞浦眺望大海，
对，就是萨奇尔夫人推行的政策之下一些变化，
对，导致了整个城市逐渐的衰老，
那些流浪汉，吸毒的人，
囚迷，老年人，青年人，
白人，黑人，
各种各样的活力和求生的本能，
在城市里面，
面对困境的时候，
如何去砰发，
所以像这样的项目，
和他后来再去做的，
有关于家庭，
有关于生活，
这种非常平静的画面，
再到最后，
他做的有关于英国的，
整个大教堂体系的这些作品，
他一直在寻找，
我作为一个摄影室，
我可以做什么不一样的东西，
这个是我的一个，
很明确的感觉，
是，而且就像刚刚他在小片里面讲的，
他试图让眼前的景象，
就是让照片自然发生，
但这是一件不容易的事情，
特别是对于摄影师来说，
当你看到一个场景的时候，
我们大多数时候都是在追寻照片，
至少到今天为止，
我觉得我还没有能够，
找到让照片自然发生的方法，
还是我想去拍什么，
我努力的去寻找这个场景，
在项目里面，
我发现了缺失的东西，
我去寻找这个缺失，
好像很难很难说，
让照片自然发生，
所以他也提到说，
信心很重要，
对，你要相信他，
然后可能是一种心境，
就经验极累，
然后加上他的这种自然的，
这种放松的状态，
以及可能在摄影的地位，
然后成就，
都能够带来这种信心，
就觉得我拍什么，
其实也可以，
那些东西我拍过了，是吧？
对，这是很现实的，
就是相同的一个题材，
我们普通人去拍，
跟已经是大师的人去拍，
就是不一样，
对，比如说保了格雷厄姆的那个，
巴黎11月15号那个项目，
就我不敢想像，
如果是我拍出那样东西，
我会挨到什么样的吗？
对，他们也会挨骂，
但至少影响力是不一样的，
对，真正要提到那个话，
我们就穿插一下，
跟大家介绍一下那个项目，
我觉得挺有意思的，
就是2015年，
还是2016年的11月份，
巴黎遭受了历史上最严重的恐怖袭，
当时保罗格雷厄姆和他家人，
正在巴黎度假，
他住的那个MBNB，
就在恐怖袭机的这个位置的楼上，
所以他们那个街区就被封锁了，
他有几天时间被困在街区里面，
无法离开，
他就用一个非常简单的方式，
去记录了在时间变化过程中，
自己情绪的变化，
在自己的住的这个MBNB的房间里面，
拍摄光线的缓脉挪动，
窗台，沙发，地板，
你可以看到几张照片，
构图完全相同，
只有光线非常轻微轻微的变化，
在里边一个一个一个一个，
堆截成了一本小小的书，
就你第一次看的时候，
你一定会觉得，
这在拍啥呀，
这是什么呀，
也没有文字介绍，
也没有说明，
然后你要看到标题才知道，
哦，原来是这个时期，
这样的故事，
就如果是一个，
不是像保罗那样子的摄影师，
我们某一个人去拍了这样的作品，
我觉得很难被认可，
而且有人愿意为他出书，
对，有人愿意为他出书，
对,
所以这也是一方面吧，
我觉得，
是的,
这是一个非常现实的问题，
对,
就是艺术是由艺术家创造的，
但,
但还是要去拍，
你拍了才有机会，
对,
当然,
那么回到，
Peter的这些项目里边，
我自己觉得最有意思的项目之一，
就是,
刚才诺本提到的，
这个鞋盒是飞机超音速飞标的，
这个类型，
1977年的11月22号，
鞋盒式科技开通了，
伦敦至纽约的航线，
把之前8个小时的行程，
缩短到了3.5小时，
由于是它的关系，
你甚至可以在另一个城市，
飞机起飞之前就抵达，
一个城市，
就非常神奇的一个体验，
就是画时代的一个产物，
对,
但是随着时间的发展，
大家发现它带来的副作用也很大，
说音报，
可能会引起周边的玻璃的震动，
震碎了玻璃，
油价高涨，
然后因为票价太高，
也没有市场，
所以,
没有多长时间，
2003年的时候，
这个就退役了，
Bitmallow就是,。
记录了鞋盒式飞机的，
最后几个月时间，
然后这个项目的名字，
叫做最后的夏天，
还出了一本书，
还办了一场展来，
去记录，
在这个时候，
公众心中引发的各种情绪，
以及它的退役消息传出之后，
普通人的，
这种感怀的状态，
虽然大多数人，
其实做不起这个飞机的，
但是每个人都认为，
它是一个跨时代的产物，
它是一个，
即使国家力量的象征，
它也是，
面向未来的可能性，
但你会发现，
这种可能性，
从你面前消失的时候，
普通人的这样子的伤感，
还是能够看得到的？
是,
而且,
它有一大波粉丝，
其实，就爱好者，
对,
你看到它照片里面，
有很多人，
是拿着望远镜，
在观察这个飞机，
是的,
它其实飞得非常快，
嗯,
它好像，
最严重是，
它对,
甚至那个臭氧层，
已经造成了，
危害,
对,
这个项目有意思的地方，
对我来说的话，
我觉得是，
我看到了一些，
拍摄的方式，
嗯,
当我去记录一个，
客机的，
最后的职业生涯的时候，
它没有把所有的视线，
都放在客机本身，
或者是航空公司本身，
飞机的，
一些部件，
这些东西上边，
它把很多的，
经历用来拍摄普通人，
在路边观看的人，
这种,
飞机迷，
或者叫航迷，
嗯,
他们记录下来的，
飞行手册，
是,
然后在周边，
找到了一些餐厅，
它里面又挂着，
嗯,
大幅的这个，
鞋盒式飞机的张铁海报，
嗯,
然后卖模型，
对,
这个模型是空的，
模型的盒子，
泡沫箱，
是,
所以这些，
小小的细节，
进入场景，
反而让整个世界，
变得更加的，
完整,
然后变得更加的，
丰满,
我觉得这是一个，
很好的启发，
是,
这里面我觉得，
还有两个点，
一个就是，
它跟项目之间的连结，
嗯,
就首先，
它父亲是参与了，
鞋盒式飞机，
发动机的研发，
对,
这就,
至少,
我跟这个飞机之间，
是有关联的，
就,
创作的合理性，
对,
然后,
第二个点，
也是优势吧，
因为这个飞机的数量，
不多,
如果这个项目它想做，
甚至可以追溯，
每一架飞机，
这样的话，
项目的规模，
不至于过大，
嗯,
但是又很丰富，
是,
所以它其中，
除了那些，
飞机本身在，
空中飞行，
白天,
或者夜晚，
因为它最著名的一张，
可能是夜晚的，
蓝色的底，
对,
标志性的那一张，
我看官网也有在卖，
是,
然后,
其他白天，
飞行的也有，
然后各种民众，
拿着望远镜，
看这个飞机的场景，
是,
这些飞机被拆解之后，
进入博物馆，
进入那些，
甚至邮轮，
那些地方的场景，
是的,
还有,
一张,
我记得是，
从更高角度撫拍，
就是拆解之后，
用船把它运到博物馆去，
我看到那个，
是放在一个，
一个运输的船上，
是,
机翼已经被拆掉了，
对,
就很有意思，
整个,
呃,
退役到拆解，
然后,
被纪念的过程，
我认为就是，
做的非常完整的方式，
如果你仔细看这套照片，
或这本书的话，
你会发现，
我进入到一个项目拍摄的时候，
我可以选择的拍摄角度有哪些，
它很好地去，
讲述了一个摄影师，
一个计时摄影师，
在做一个题目的时候，
我可以从哪里去看，
对,
我觉得这个是一个，
很具有参考和，
学习价值的项目，
是的,
对,
另外的话，
我不知道你有没有看到，
他的另一个项目，
叫做家里宁格勒，
这个项目，
我其实有点没太理解，
我还蛮好奇，
那个地方到底，
之前是属于哪里，
对,
或者后期又怎么样，
因为他经历了，
按照项目闪述的说法，
他既有德国的痕迹，
澳苏联，
再是后期解体之后的，
俄罗斯的，
对,
但他很像是说，
把德国人，
从德国人手上，
拿到这块地方，
然后又鼓励俄罗斯人，
去那里住，
要把他填满，
把他填满这种感觉，
然后这个项目的起点，
我不知道当时他拍摄的起点，
是什么样子，
在马克南官网上，
写这个项目的时候，
我觉得其实有点奇怪的，
他是在2017年的时候，
还是16年的时候，
有一个著名的设计师，
时尚设计师，
在这个地方，
做了一个，
这种秀，
但是因为家里能隔了这个城市，
他其实跟时尚毫不沾边，
所以他们觉得非常反差，
由这个引入，
影子进入之后，
找到了，
Peter Marlow在2001年,。
16年前拍摄的照片，
来描绘这个城市，
但我们其实不太知道，
这辆车之间的关联是什么，
而且之前好像，
一直在强调这个城市的，
丑陋跟反差，
对,
就是包括文字作者，
好像是跟一个作家合作，
合作的对，
一个这个作家叫做，
AA吉尔,
然后说，
家里能隔了，
挥之不去的丑陋，
有一种令人安心的特质，
然后说这个，
西方文化在前，
共产主义的城市中，
悄然渗透，
胆之虑，
灰赫色，
和避云管灰色的，
公寓楼顶上，
共产主义的口号，
面包和祖国，
苏联英雄工人万岁，
依然顽强的存在，
但当下正被被纳通，
松下和可可乐的，
品牌色彩挤到一边，
家里能隔了，
不知道自己正在崛起，
还是在消失，
可能两者坚有，
其中有一张照片，
我印象很深刻，
是一个穿着，
黑色衣服的老太太，
带着一个帽子，
两手各拎了一个包，
然后走在屋里，
地面像是这种沙地，
然后背后像是山，
有一点山的感觉，
就不像在城市里，
像是在一个，
类似于穿西西藏，
这样的一个场景下，
色调也很神奇，
非常神奇，
对,
所以这张照片，
我觉得，
我看完之后，
我觉得还是，
蛮能够打动你的，
就是你能够感受到那一刻，
站在此时此地的时候的状态，
包括这个城市，
结合刚才讲的，
两者坚有的这样的，
崛起和消失，
同时发生的城市的风景吧，
对,
皮特马洛在莫奇做的，
拍摄英国大教堂这个项目，
罗本应该更有体会，
对,
但现在你也应该有很深的体会，
因为你也正在拍四屋，
老板也开始，
用四成五相机，
进行一些创作，
对,
特别推荐，
大家就去看，
他在马格南官网上，
我不知道，
应该是他自己写的，
或者说，
访谈之后，
别人记录的，
整理出来的，
就在非常非常详细的，
从技术上，
还有拍摄过程上，
他非常详细的，
记录了这个项目的创作，
对,
特别神奇，
然后脚架怎么架，
对,
包括因为东西多，
所以停车停在什么地方，
他的小推车，
使用的光圈范围，
对,
甚至道义律师校，
这些也都写在里面，
在后期用什么软件，
处理哪些内容，
然后,
三秒一，
对,
易麦康的八四八，
对吧,
那个就是，
我们现在，
哈苏X1跟X5的前身，
对,
所以他把所有的，
这些技术细节，
都写在了这篇文章里面，
就谁想去拍这个东西，
就完全可以自己，
就可以去了，
就,
特别有意思，
然后这个项目的话呢，
他其实是，
在2008年的时候，
为了纪念，
盛保罗大教堂，
建成三百年，
英国皇家邮政，
委托他拍摄了六座教堂，
包括威斯敏斯特大教堂，
那拍完之后呢，
他觉得这个项目很有意思，
于是他就花了四年时间，
拍了英国国教的，
四十二座大教堂，
所有英国国教大教堂，
都拍完了，
是一个非常当代，
非常类型学的项目，
他其中提到的一个要点，
他说,
每个教堂的中庭，
因为其实中庭建的，
规模不一样，
所以中庭的大小是不一样的，
但他希望在画面中，
为了保持这种类型学的创作方式，
需要让中庭看起来大小相似，
所以他需要把脚架，
设置在相同的高度，
相同的这样子的视角，
然后选择合适的距离，
去进行拍摄，
那大画幅其实很有优势，
因为那个毛玻璃像是有网格的嘛，
对对对，
他只要对应那个网格，
就能确保他刚刚说的那个目的，
所以从刚才所有的项目，
创作历程来看，
你可以看到他在最后期的时候，
其实是往当代艺术在走的，
是,
包括像这种非常偏类型学的创作方式，
非常非常精准的创作，
在这里的说明文字中，
甚至会像刚才说的一样，
把所有的创作细节，
分享出来，
然后以大持福的作品去制作，
包括这些一整套的逻辑，
就更偏向于当代艺术了。
对，包括他去世之后，
他的遗伤，
还有他的可能遗产，
以及基金会，
一直在寻回做展示的，
可能出现频率最高的，
就是这组作品，
对,
因为他可能从现实角度出发，
他更便于被收藏，
或者说被展示，
他也具有一定的特殊意义，
因为他纪录了整个国教系统的。
42座大教堂，
这个很符合类型学的一个方法，
就是收集整理展示。
那在收集这件事情上，
他其实把一个一类的图片，
收集完整了，
所以也让自己的创作，
变得非常非常的完善吧，
应该来说。
所以他无论是展示，
收藏,
还是出售，
可能都会具有天然的优势。
对,
我们可以根据他写的那篇文章，
聊一聊他的技术。
来,
首先他用的，
他用的一台是仙娜的FE相机，
而这台相机很平衡，
F系列,
它是Filled的，
而大家知道仙娜最专业的就是P系列，
就几乎所有的商业工作室都会用到那台机器，
但那机器又大又重，
可能只适合放在工作室里面。
对，彭丽。
对，后期他们又研发了Filled的产品线，
在保留单轨，
非常高精度的基础上，
做出了更轻量化的这个相机，
它携带会有一定的便携性，
对，但他还是提到说，
自己每次创作的时候带的东西会非常多，
相比双轨还是非常大，
因为这个相机，
它有轨道，
然后它有那个底座，
它可以调它的刻度，
所以当时可能又想出去拍摄，
又想保留大化夫的精度的摄影师，
会使用F这个系列的相机，
可以说他在整个创作中，
是非常非常考究细节的，
他还提到他在教堂拍摄的时候，
把一些，比如说，
经文的书，
或者是一些广告牌，
招式牌，活动宣传的这些海报，
全部都挪掉，
除了两张照片里面有无法挪掉的印记灯，
后期是用PS处理掉的之外，
其他的话都是现场挪走的，
所以这个许可也很不容易，
是，人家可能过几个小时就要做礼拜的，
对,
然后你还在那搬东西，
对的,
而且他可能买了当时最高的脚架，
就漫幅图的而且是，
而且配了最高的脚架之后，
又去买了一架，
多少，他六银尺高的，
我具体忘了一个单位，
就他买了一个梯子，
所以他用了非常高的一个视角来拍摄，
是的,
你可以看到他整个的中线位置是非常高，
而且他的整个前组升降已经升到极限了，
对,
某一些照片我们可以看出来，
首先他顶部，
如果没有，
他是没有使用灯光的，
对,
所以教堂顶部本身按的情况下，
再加上他通过遗轴，
额，抬到最高的角度之后，
其实是有一些按部的，
有些细节会有差别，
是的,
因为他升得很极限了已经，
对,
所以一个高的机位对这个项目的拍摄是非常有帮助的，
各自高其实也很好，
那天我跟Android，
就是我的一个学生去拍摄，
因为他个子高嘛，
所以他把这个中轴也升起来了，
然后机位非常高，
他对好胶之后，
他在做一个前组的抚养的动作，
然后他说，
我有点看不出来，
他说,
我过去之后，
我得跳着开，
特别丢脸，
以前我就讲，
最早我用那个，
结性的，
那个五系的最高的脚架，
他能升到2米18，
然后我想，
姚明其实拿着相机，
他就可以获得这个视角，
所以各自高其实还是很有优势的，
在这种拍摄的过程中，
拍出来的东西就不一样，
升高到用时方恨矮，
然后他的镜头，
跟你现在，
你不刚买了那个120的镜头吗，
对，老板从150，
现在换到了120的一颗镜头，
所以,
他这个时候呢，
是115好像，
对，跟120很接近了，
说到这个的话，
我正好其实想要跟ROBIN请教一下，
我觉得，
你觉不觉得，
150,
虽然说好像等效，
50,
标头,
大概是标头的样子，
但是他的，
跟135,
或者是120的标头的视觉，
感受是完全不一样的，
我不知道为什么，
就是我其实很习惯用标头，
像我在莱卡也是用的标头，
用的比较多的这个这个胶段，
但是我在，
45上我就会觉得他很挤，
是拍摄的时候吗，
拍摄的时候，
那因为我们，
就是取景方式完全不一样，
对,
我认为是这样的，
我觉得差别会很大，
就是我在135上使用的时候，
我觉得我的，
留给自己的拍摄空间，
还是很大的，
进可攻退可守，
50这个胶段，
或者标头这个胶段，
我就觉得很好用，
40到50,
但是在45上使用的时候，
我就总觉得他，
有点卡，
有点挤，
所以我回来之后，
我就赶紧换了一个120，
是，我有这种感受，
因为我，
之前黄龙那个项目，
我一直全是用，
150毫米这个镜头拍摄的，
可能我觉得，
因为我们使用了三角架，
而且大部分我们拍摄的时候，
其实预先设定了这个机位，
对，你不会这样，
对，我假设就是，
我是在这儿不动的，
我看好之后，
也可能可以稍微挪动一下，
就至少没有你手持相机那么灵活，
我倒是有这个前提在，
可能是这样，
可能我以我某一个视角，
选定了一个机位之后，
我就定在那儿，
然后我就不太想了，
明明你是可以走的，
然后我就设定，
我是定在这儿的，
有可能，有可能，
反正就是感觉上，
视觉上会有点奇怪，
所以我就换了120，
可以先拍摄一段时间，
感受一下，
但他可能要求鞋更高，
因为你囊阔了更多的内容之后，
对你对整个画面的把控，
你需要更多的时间，
去观察画面的视角，
和周边的细节，
来确保你没有，
融入那些对于画面构成，
没有帮助，
甚至会有损害的一些元素，
是的,
期待你的大画幅的作品，
我努力，
然后甚至他说了，
他用的是什么胶片，
然后大致使用的，
镜头的光圈，
22-32,
因为他首先要获得，
比较,
比较长的景深的话，
他就需要用小光圈，
对,
但是还有个问题，
就是他所有都在，
没有光源的情况下拍摄，
所以基本上，
曝光时间都是一到五分钟，
这已经对胶片来说，
到一个失效的问题，
所以他并不是固定在某个光圈，
他是固定的时间，
对,
所以他要，
设定不同的光圈，
来对应不同的场景，
就是技术上，
其实真的给的很细节，
对,
非常神奇，
而且提到他用那个，
复制的，
斯拉片，
来做一个参考，
他的用量挺大的，
就是一个教堂，
好像他要拍到，
五张,
五至十六张，
好像他说的是，
然后再拍到五张斯拉片，
胶片的话，
可能要，
一盒打底，
我估计是一个教堂，
嗯,
还挺贵的，
对,
他那个时候应该便宜，
但挺神奇的，
为什么要，
用这么多胶片呢，
呃,
你既然已经固定了技术，
我固定了这些参数，
为什么需要这么多胶片，
去拍这样的一个场景呢，
我其实，
我不是特别理解这个，
对,
但我们可以稍微延伸一下，
他可能，
呃，不是我后面要说的，
这样去拍摄啊，
因为他里面没有提到，
我觉得他如果那么做的话，
他肯定会写，
因为我所认识的，
有一批大画幅摄影师，
他每张，
因为有，
呃,
就是,
亮部跟暗部，
他拍摄的时候，
他拍的要拍，
同一个场景，
他要不同的，
三到五张胶片，
然后回到，
呃,
回来暗房之后，
他有更多的操作的可能性，
嗯,
他应该没那么做，
因为他没有，
他没有提到，
因为他那一篇文章，
简直是像说明书一样，
对,
但其实他可以这么去做，
因为我们照片看到，
从教堂的中庭，
到教堂的顶部，
其实已经，
这个,
已经跨度挺大了，
嗯,
这个明暗度的跨度，
对,
因为教堂里面的光源，
其实有的时候会很集中，
所以你看到的地方，
有地方会非常亮，
然后没有光线的地方，
就会非常非常爱，
其实技术上是很难拍的了，
教堂,
是的，说不定他用了，
他没写，
还是有所保留的，
也有可能，
要不然的话，
没有理由拍这么多张，
去拍这样一个固定的场景，
对,
他并不是在教堂里面，
四周去拍，
他就只拍中庭的一个方向，
对,
对吧,
嗯,
对,
其实也有这个可能，
然后他提到，
他的扫描仪的话，
就是,
一麦康的848，
848,
就是被哈苏收购之后的，
X1跟X5,
是,
这个就是，
哈苏扫描仪的前身，
嗯,
对，也是当时，
精度非常高的扫描仪，
最高了，
但令人遗憾的是，
在2016年的2月，
马洛因为多发性骨髓流，
移植引发的流感，
就不幸事事了，
嗯,
他的遗霜，
创立了，
彼得马洛基金会，
后续他有，
推出非常多，
针对,
青年摄影师的扶持项目，
非常棒，
大家可以去关注一下，
对,
因果摄影师，
我觉得对于年轻一辈的，
这种扶持，
还是挺多的，
挺了不起的，
大家可以关注一下，
包括马丁帕尔，
包括马洛都，
成立了基金会，
对,
所以,
聊到这里的话，
我们今天的主线内容，
差不多了，
然后,
最后我们回归到，
我们常规的一个小讨论，
就是从这位摄影师身上，
我们能够学到什么，
嗯,
其实最开始，
是源于小方片，
后面写的，
让照片自然发生那个点，
我觉得也是，
大家可以，
呃，去尝试，
甚至,
呃,
值得去实践的，
我觉得，
但是后来，
我看到他另一句，
他写了更多，
就他一句话里面，
包含了很多，
你能学习的东西，
对,
我可以稍微，
呃,
先分享这个点，
他说的是，
呃,
做真实的自己，
早点起床，
不要太用力，
因为任何，
你试图，
流露出来的东西，
最终,
都会毫不费力的呈现出来，
嗯,
学会信任你的直觉，
也不要过度，
成立于，
创作的过程，
努力工作，
但享受其中，
你这是非常中肯，
也,
包含了很多东西的一句话，
很人生哲学的一句话，
是的,
首先就是，
早点起床，
对,
我觉得他解构了，
甚至是，
当代摄影教育中的一些问题，
就比如，
呃,
概念化的陷阱，
是,
现在非常非常泛滥，
就是,
近期应该有很多毕业展，
呃,
我看到很多评论，
就可能大部分，
讨论是，
然后,
他也将摄影重新定义为，
一项,
我是需要，
非常诚实的，
而且需要生理劳动，
去实践的一个，
一,
一项活动，
就是我们一直在说的，
对于摄影来说，
你必须要在现场，
你必须要走到那里去拍，
这也是，
确实,
就像刚刚Robin说的一样，
很多的，
摄影,
创作,
太过于强调观念，
而太少，
走出现场，
我,
我觉得，
这也是，
确实是我们这个时代的问题，
嗯,
不知道他是不是进步，
来说,
我觉得他是一个问题，
嗯,
那么,
就从刚才你说的，
早点起床开始，
你是有什么感慨吗？
哈哈哈，
没有,
我起得很糟，
OK,
因为,
他拍那个大教堂项目的时候，
呃,
好像,
他设定了另外一个条件，
就是要，
清晨的地狱铝光，
嗯,
就是,
他是在天位亮之前，
进入了这个，
这个教堂，
对,
呃,
早起,
不仅是，
很多摄影师，
获得某种引调，
只是一种，
我觉得，
习惯跟态度，
对,
因为我，
你还记得我之前，
不是,
我的毕业项目，
拍的是一个，
巴黎的早晨吗？
日出之前，
呃,
是马克帕尔问我的问题，
他说,
你为什么，
现在的技术，
已经这么发达了，
后期,
你完全可以做到，
你可以在拍摄的时候，
捡爆三档，
在后期再要捡爆一档，
你就可以做出，
日出前的这样的影像，
你为什么要，
每天早上那么早起去拍摄？
嗯,
我当时，
是,
对,
所以,
早起的那一瞬间，
你的感受，
然后,
这些东西，
是没有办法，
用后期来替代的，
对啊,
它整体那个环境，
对,
就是某一种，
某一种像，
感官玻璃，
对,
就是我玻璃掉了，
日常那种曹杂，
还有噪音的隔绝，
是的,
嗯,
这个还蛮重要，
是的,
就,
就像你说的，
不要骗自己，
对,
你骗不了感觉，
骗不了感官，
要过度堆砌沉重的，
这种,
社会批判概念，
嗯,
因为,
某一些，
技巧,
或者炫目的后期，
其实当一个，
创作者，
脑中,
如果装满了，
这种,
繁琐的艺术评论词汇，
和对,
某种,
画廊销售的，
这种,
功力的考量吧，
可能直觉就会，
受影响，
对,
因为,
这也是，
当下的一个问题，
对,
你看到，
很多画廊的，
这种词汇堆叠在一起，
就是,
AI都想不出，
这么高妙的话，
是,
就,
以前我一直觉得，
我自己文化不够，
看不懂，
后来发现有了AI，
我还是看不懂，
还有第三个点，
就是,
信任你的直觉，
不要过多，
想别人的看法，
这个我觉得，
倒是蛮重要的，
因为,
在你创作过程，
甚至展览，
或者呈现的过程当中，
会有,
非常非常多的，
外界的声音，
是,
怎么去，
应对他们，
怎么去处理他们，
呃,
之前有一个学生，
跟我说，
他说,
他不想要，
过早的，
把照片发到，
社交媒体上，
他的社交媒体，
基本上，
就只有自己的生活，
或者是一些，
很日常的场景，
他拍的东西，
其实拍得很不错，
我说,
那你为什么不，
分享一些自己的作品呢，
他说,
他在,
刚刚开始，
创作这个阶段，
他不想要，
受到外界的干扰，
他觉得，
发上去之后，
就会有不同的声音，
有人说好，
这个好的声音，
让他的创作方向，
我觉得这个，
其实挺聪明的，
嗯,
对,
因为他很理性，
知道自己会受，
这些东西影响，
所以我就不受这影响，
我选择不受影响，
我觉得这个很好，
嗯,
对,
而他认为，
摄影是，
最具身体性的，
没界,
就像前面，
他所说的，
这就是一个，
生理劳动的活动，
对,
摄影是，
民工活，
要不然，
怎么能叫，
摄影民工呢，
那我觉得，
对我来说的，
专注在，
或者是，
不要被某种风格，
所束缚，
你看,
Peter Marlowe,。
早期的，
即时影像，
黑白的作品，
到中期的时候，
用,
应该是，
类似于哈苏或者路来，
他先用中画，
中画服，
中画服，数码还教片，
呃,
具体我忘了，
哪个项目，
他甚至用过六成七的，
对,
应该是教片，
就6667,
然后彩色的影像，
有一张我印象，
特别深刻的照片，
像喷泉一样的水池里面，
有一辆，
购物车，
半淹没在里边，
特别特别，
哲学的一张图片，
风格的明显的变化，
再到后期，
刚才我们一直在说的，
这个英国教堂的项目，
转用四成五的大画幅，
非常技术，
非常精致的拍摄，
那,
他其实从来没有，
考虑过说，
Peter Marlowe,。
我应该是什么样的，
摄影风格，
而是我在人生的不同阶段，
我如何看待我的摄影，
我如何看待摄影这件事情，
所以我会创作不同的东西，
我会更喜欢这样的方式，
这就是我，
我觉得我从中学到的东西，
更好的让我坚持，
应该这么做吧，
就不断的尝试，
不断尝试新的东西，
不断的尝试新的风格，
不断的尝试新的主题，
而在节目的最后，
我在讲一个比较有意思的点，
就是当时他提到
自己要转型的时候，
他说了一句话，
他说我拍摄了那么多，
即时项目之后，
我发现我自己
永远成不了唐麦克林，
大家似乎把他作为一个标杆，
对,
战机摄影的标杆，
可能还稍微带一点点，
细学在里面，
我觉得可能就是，
可能是他年轻的时候的某种设想，
就是我希望成为那个样子，
但是我的风格跟别人，
跟他是不一样的，
所以我永远成不了那个样子，
我觉得我们都会有，
我不知道Roman会不会，
你脑海里面会不会有想说，
我可能会拍成某一个人的样子，
但是随着我的创作，
我会发现我永远不会变成那个样子，
你会有一个自己心里面的标杆在，
但是你会跟这个标杆走得越来越远，
挺有意思的，
好的,
那今天节目就到这里，
感谢大家收听我们的小方片，
我们下期节目再见，
拜拜!